are you the one person in the universe
who's never read harry potter
ever since harry potter flew onto the
scene and into our hearts
we can't help but compare every modern
fantasy story that comes along
to the boy who lived with netflix fate
the wink saga
we get to see even more of that
comparison first hand
the beloved animated children series the
winx club is next in line in getting the
young adult fiction makeover
in addition to being live action netflix
seems to have gone a much darker route
than the original source material
it's pretty obvious there are some
similarities between fate the wink saga
and harry potter both harry and bloom
lead a life without any magic
oh you're not from the other world i'm
not it wasn't until their pivotal
respective ages
harriet 11 bloomin 16 but they would
discover the world of magic
and realize they have magical abilities
too stick your right hand
over the broom and say up
both protagonists have to quickly adapt
to their new environment while
understanding their powers a challenge
that doesn't seem easy
at all you're a great wizard you really
are
the show is self-aware enough to realize
the hogwarts comparison
and bloom confesses you knew how many
hours i have wasted taking sorting hat
quizzes
aisha immediately guesses she's a
ravenclaw
sometimes slytherin bloom fires back
with i guess gryffindor
explains the judgment we love this fun
nod to harry potter and
knowing that even fairies take hogwarts
quizzes
way before harry or bloom arrived at
their respective magical worlds
their destiny was laid out long before
they even knew magic existed
let alone how important they both were
it's revealed in the trailer that bloom
has the potential to beat
one of the most powerful fairies in
addition to a mysterious past that
neither she
nor the audience knows about yet
circumstances surrounding your birth is
much a mystery to me as they are to you
sounds pretty familiar to the boy who
lived we think
she thinks you're the chosen one but i
am the chosen one
okay sorry um from what we know there
seems to be an impending war heading
towards the winx crew
it looks like bloom will be a large part
of that battle possibly because of her
mysterious past and extremely powerful
magic
we're barricading all entrances to the
courtyard but
we must prepare for the reality this is
very similar to the series long war
between lord voldemort and harry potter
where harry was thrust into the middle
because of the prophecy of him being the
chosen one
and defeating voldemort when he was a
baby in addition to both being boarding
schools for magical students
the schools themselves are hidden inside
of a magical barrier that keeps any
unwanted visitors
none the wiser the schools are hidden to
the normal human eye
and they also keep evil entities out
although as we've seen with hogwarts
that's not always a successful plan
here's hoping the magic charm around
althea will be a little stronger than
the one around hogwarts
it's very impressive isn't it
if the live action reboot is anything
like the animated series
then headmistress ferraganda is alfia's
version of dumbledore
farraganda is known for being kind but
firm and mysterious with a rich history
she's also seen as a mentor to the main
characters open yourself up to the magic
of the world around you
just like the beloved headmaster of
hogwarts himself
who wanted to find the stone find it
but not use it both bloom and harry
learn that they have some sort of powers
before they ever step foot on campus
we hope that one iconic moment from the
animated series makes it to the netflix
show
and that's when bloom helps fight off a
troll using her magic for the first time
but without knowing she has magical
powers similarly
harry discovers his abilities on
dudley's birthday trip to the zoo
when he speaks to the snake and releases
him from his tank
thanks anytime
what magic school wouldn't be complete
without some sort of dark mystery
given what we know about fate a key
storyline will be the winks discovering
the secrets involving alfia
we need more and we'll get it because
rosalind's alive
hogwarts is no stranger to this concept
from basilisks
to the ever-evolving defense against the
dark arts teachers we can definitely see
a similarity between the two schools in
this regard
probably the most obvious similarity
between harry potter and fate the winx
saga
is their main backdrop being a boarding
school for magical children and teens
the althea school is home to many young
magical individuals who are honing their
skills
it also holds many secrets our heroes
must discover
sound familiar if you didn't tell us
otherwise we'd think you were describing
the one and only hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry
what are you doing wandering the
corridors at night
one of our favorite parts about watching
harry potter are the incredible
fight scenes everything looks so much
cooler with magic
the action sequences throughout the
series are iconic
from what we know about the fate series
spectacular action scenes will be just
as much a part of their storyline
students at alfia are trained in combat
in addition to learning about their
powers
much like the animated series that
inspired the new netflix show
there's an ensemble cast of fairies that
become close friends with bloom
each fairy has a unique power they
perfect while in school
along with their own personalities that
make them an essential part of the team
while there have been a few
controversial changes to the original
lineup of fairies
we found several counterparts between
the live-action winx squad and the young
order of the phoenix members
and well done everyone great great work
it turns out that fate existed
long before it was adapted for netflix
fate is based on the italian animated
children's show
the winx club which ran from 2004 to
2019.
edgy neostrophy creator of the winx club
serves as
executive producer on fate and strafie
has wanted to make a live action version
of the winx club as far back as 2011.
as we know the eight harry potter movies
are inspired by
the seven book series written by jk
rowling so both had a built-in fan base
beforehand
what's a group of teenagers at a magical
boarding school to do without a little
mischief
from what we know it looks like the
fairies get themselves in some hot water
at least once in the series how
thoughtless you were
we'll discuss consequences in the
morning the clip shown in the
behind-the-scenes interview with the
cast brings to mind another iconic
friend group getting caught up in some
trouble
both get a talking to but we're sure
that the wings will land back
on their feet like the golden trio
always did when something happens
it is always you three
all the fantastical magic and epic
battle scenes aside
the core of fate is the strong
friendships brian young who developed
the series for netflix describes in an
interview that he considers fate to be
this show as the origin story of a
friend group
magical elements aside we think it's
pretty sweet that the real magic at the
forefront
is friendship harry potter was similar
where they always made time to show the
strong bond the golden trio shared
what would a coming-of-age show be
without a little pure rivalry
the original series had a group of
sisters known as the tricks who were
some of the antagonists to bloom and the
rest of the winx club
to us it's not too far away from draco
malfoy in the entire slytherin house
brian young shared that there will be
some elements of that brought to the
netflix show
we've also got troublemaker beatrix who
might remind fans of one of the trick
sisters
we know that harry potter is a tried and
true british series
but fate has a more complicated history
than that as mentioned earlier
the winx club was originally an italian
animated show which is interesting that
the live-action fate is
seemingly british at least based on the
character's accents in the setting
every failure brings you one step closer
to success
one final similarity we found is that
the main friend group
lives together at school actress elliot
salt explains that
focuses on one suite and ours is the
wink suite so there's five girls all
living there and they all have different
kind of fairy powers we got to watch the
gryffindors grow up and live together in
the gryffindor common room
much like it'll be for the fairies and
fate after watching this video
we think there's some undeniable
similarities between the two we can't
unsee
now so viewers do you think fate the
wink saga and harry potter have some
uncanny similarities
or is it just a result of both being set
in a fantasy world
let us know in the comments